[Music]
queen elizabeth ii had an unparalleled
reign
the effect of which has been felt across
the world
in her record-breaking seven decades on
the throne
she witnessed the end of the british
empire
and welcomed radical societal shifts
she was the first person in the uk to
make a long-distance phone call without
an operator the first monarch in the
world to send an email and one of the
first to tweet the queen's reign was
monumental in absolutely every sense it
was peppered with superlatives she was
the longest reigning british monarch her
head appeared on more coins than any
other living monarch she was herself
like a monument unchanging
through it all britain's satisfaction
with the queen averaged close to 80
percent here's the story of her
remarkable reign in numbers
through the gates of buckingham palace
queen elizabeth ii's coronation was on
june 2nd 1953 bringing a beautiful and
radiant girl to her coronation she was
only 27 when she formally devoted her
life to the crown
by the end of that life she had reigned
over a britain that was vastly
transformed
for one thing its population was a lot
older
in 1953 only 11 of britons were over 65.
by 2020 that had risen to 19
and the queen was an oddity she was a
woman with a job
only 26
of british women were in the labor force
in the 1950s
by 2021 72 of women worked
when elizabeth came to the throne she
ruled over in england that was whiter
more conservative and more traditional
than the one we see around us now
through her reign the country's views on
same-sex marriage
race relations
and women's rights
have all dramatically liberalized
but there was no such dramatic shift in
support for the monarchy
throughout it never dipped below 60
percent
perhaps that was down to the queen's
inscrutable nature
the queen had a talent for saying a lot
while saying almost nothing at all
she was almost the perfect
constitutional monarch nobody knew what
she thought there's nothing more
enigmatic than not knowing what somebody
thinks
if being an enigma was part of the
reason for her popularity
so too was her dedication to her role
and the royal yacht sails into wolf's
cove to receive a salute of welcome
[Music]
the queen worked incredibly hard at her
job
in 2017 at the age of 91 she attended
292 public engagements
and when her husband of 73 years the
duke of edinburgh died she took only
four days off
she also went through her red box
a case filled with government papers for
her attention
daily throughout her seven decade reign
taking time off for just christmas day
and easter
one of the things that her prime
ministers have said it's very clear she
has a very good grasp of what is going
on you don't impress with your knowledge
of british state without working at it
and the queen's role extended far beyond
one small island
in 1953 she reigned over a dwindling
british empire
she was head of state for 55 overseas
territories
by 2021 just 14 of these remained
singapore means lion city so it's
appropriate that lions and dragons
should take part in the independent
celebrations ending all our
constitutional links with britain was
proclaimed and given the royal seal of
approval
as the empire disappeared the
commonwealth grew a voluntary club of
countries with the queen at its head
by 2021 its 54 member states were home
to 2.4 billion people across five
continents
that the commonwealth has remained
strong it feels like one of those
diplomatic puzzles
it's kind of the ghost of the empire and
of all the things you would think that
who would want to belong to it
and it was often felt that the thing
that was really holding it together was
her
in her reign elizabeth visited almost
every commonwealth country
in fact traveling to her overseas
territories was one of the first things
she did as queen
the five-month tour takes the royal
couple first to africa then to ceylon
australia and new zealand
between november 1953 and may 1954
she visited 14 in an epic tour around
the world
black star square the enormous parade
ground in the centre of accra seven
years later she visited ghana the
country was suffering deep political
turmoil the queen and president in
krumer first drove past the 5 000 troops
days before she arrived bombs were going
off in the capital city of accra
but she went anyway to a roaring
reception
whatever else is blown into the limbo of
history
the personal guide and affection which
we in ghana
have for your majesty
and for your royal highness
what do you mean
even beyond the commonwealth she loved
to explore the world she was probably
the most well-traveled monarch in
history visiting over 100 countries
she met 13 uf presidents
and five popes
but it wasn't just the many people the
queen met whom she made an impression on
the whole world knew who the queen was
one of the photos that was taken off her
that was on the british stamp for
decades is thought to have been the most
reproduced photograph in history
her image had appeared on more coins
than any other living monarch for that
alone
she was one of the most famous women in
the world
she was portrayed in 100 films and tv
shows from the sublime
to the ridiculous queen ladies and
gentlemen
and a gallup poll listed her as one of
the world's top 10 most admired women 52
times
that's more than mother teresa and oprah
winfrey combined
elizabeth ii was one of the world's
longest reigning monarchs
surpassed only by louis xiv of france
the numbers behind queen elizabeth ii's
remarkable reign speak for themselves
but perhaps her most enduring legacy is
the way in which she ruled
the queen's stoic devotion to her rule
was legendary it said that before her
coronation to get used to the immense
weight of her crown resting upon her
head she used to practice by wearing it
at breakfast
and in a way she never took it off again
to see more of the economist's coverage
of the death of queen elizabeth ii
click the link
you